مرحبا نجوم قادرين على خطف الضوء
والكاميرا من اي فنان يقف امامهم بعد
الاحيان لا يكون هؤلاء النجوم هم ابطال
العمل بالنجوم مساندين لهم لكنهم ملفتين
اكثر منهم اسباب كثيره تقف خلف ذلك في
مقدمتها ادائهم الجيد واحيانا كاريزمتهم
وحركتهم وتفاصيل اخرى اعتقد انه بقت من
سنن دراما رمضان انه الوجوه التانيه
الادوار التانيه او الثالثه هي البريق
اللي بيصنع
الدراما الحقيقيه واعتقد ان هم اللي
بيبقوا خير سند للابطال والشخصيات الكبرى
يعني
من غير هؤلاء تحس ان النجوم مش واخدين
ريحتهم وما بيحققوش النجاح المطلوب خلاص
انتهى عصر دراما البطل الواحد في نجوم
سنويين او اصحاب ابطال ادوار ثانويه قدر
يبقى لهم تواجد جيد قدروا يقدموا بصمتهم
الشخصيه من الاسامي دي مثلا الثلاث فنانات
اللي عاملين دول زوجات جعفر العمده سواء
او ايمان العاصي او منه فضالي او حتى زينه
احنا ما نقدرش نقول ان زينا بطله سنويه
لكن الاربعه دول لهم تواجد قوي في رمضان
الحالي لعبه العديد من الاسماء الكبيره
بطوله المشتركه كان البعض فيها لافتا اكثر
من الاخر بينما وفي مسلسلات اخرى هناك
نجوم سنويين تفوقوا على الابطال المطلقين
وحظوا بكامل الثناء ومن هنا قد تبدا معهم
رحله فنيه مختلفه هتلاقي في مسلسل رشيد
الشخصيات التانيه او الثالثه
عبله عامل مؤثر هتلاقي في علاقه مشروعه
هتلاقي في في سوق الكانتو هتلاقي في
الكتيبه 101 هتلاقي في حتى في مسلسل رساله
الامام هتلاقي ده موجود
هتلاقي في جعفر العمده بص كده وراقب
الشخصيات اللي بتقدم ادوار تانيه او تالته
دايما هي اللي بتفرش للبطل وده من هي نقطه
الانطلاق في الصراع الدرامي الجمهور ايضا
كان هناك من الفت نظره بشده من النجوم
الثانويين فمن كان ابرزهم
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات